Elaine is in Harrisburg Pennsylvania
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Elaine I
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up we have a rental property
and our last tenants trashed it
so with legal fees and everything that
we had to get them evict it it put and
the unpaid rent put us down about ten
thousand dollars to get it ready for
another tenant to move in is going to
cost about nine to ten thousand dollars
on top of that that we've lost now what
we'd like to do down the road that we've
talked about for years is VRBO it would
take instead of the nine to ten thousand
to fix it up for an for a new tenant it
would take about twelve to fifteen
thousand and either way anything that we
do we're going to have to dip into our
emergency fund because all of the
illegal fees and everything were taken
the money that we had in the rental
account we're used up with those items
so I wanted your advice do you think we
should go with the lower amount and have
someone move in and use the money from
the rent to save up to get it ready for
VRBO or now should we take our time
getting it ready and and take the extra
money out of our emergency fund and do
that now okay so to get it ready for the
market at ten thousand dollars you have
the ten thousand dollars without
touching your emergency fund no no that
would still be out of the emergency fund
how much is in your emergency fund about
thirty and what's your household income
about eighty five gross okay so the
difference in ten thousand our merchants
are under twelve thousand I'm your
emergency fund doesn't really matter
does it
mm I mean you're gonna do one of the
other right right it's just a matter
which way you want to run this property
so have you figured out how you screwed
up as a landlord yes you know what it
was we were desperate we wanted to get
somebody in and had a bad feeling but
thought I was helping someone out and I
should have gone with the bad feeling
but yeah right after I get desperate I
usually get stupid and right yeah right
after I get stupid I usually get broke
and yeah every time I'd me is just this
pattern in my life I've had to stop
doing it so when I start feeling myself
desperate I just tap the brakes and take
a chill pill and go waiting that gods in
charge I'm not doing this because yeah
you knew this was bad folk and then you
didn't follow up and you didn't lean on
them I mean you let them stay in there
you never know everything back to the
property you never followed up you
didn't push you let him stay in there
like two three months too long well I
was in the property regularly yeah how
about a [ __ ] dogs well I mean if you're
in the property and it's going down
buying you a victim and I started that
process and it they had to be like I
think it was a full month behind in rent
before my attorney said that I would
have any also you need your leash and
you need a new lease that says if
they're not taking care of the property
they can be evicted regardless of the
rent okay yeah so this is what I mean
this is landlord experience you're
having here so every time I do something
like this and I lose money because
somebody takes my freaking head off
which is what happened here I want to
know where that shot came from and I
want to duck it next time I want to
learn what happened so like you know you
change your lease you change your
process on how you handle people and by
the way VRBO is no magic pill there's
crazy there's crazy people around VRBO
houses all the time so it's not like
it's got an exclusive to non crazy
tenants or something they'll trash you
know you'll get some you know
Bachelorette weekend in there
they'll rip the paint off the walls man
I mean it's you have to watch what
you're doing whatever whoever you're
letting in your property and so you need
a very strict Villar br br bo rules are
you in a resort setting Wow er bo why
would anybody bother it's in the country
it's for people who want to get away you
think there's a market I did check on on
VRBO and there are other properties in
the area I'm going to say within a
20-mile radius that are doing it contact
those owners as if they ever in them
there are reviews on and I've read the
reviews but yeah that I can do that I've
used to other reviews two years old and
they ran it once every two hours I mean
you know here's the thing if you don't
rent VRBO at least fifty percent of time
you're not even breaking even on a
traditional rental right it's double but
you know so you gotta you got to keep it
full 50 percent they break even on a
traditional rental and it's a lot more
hassle a lot more trouble on your part I
mean you can do it I don't care but make
sure that there's enough market to keep
it full fifty percent and then you've
got a ride herd on this all the time and
I don't care which one you do ten
thousand twelve thousand dozen army you
got to put your emergency fund back as
soon as you get this thing fixed back up
but what whichever one you do go back
and say yeah these people were scum yes
they were you know they let their dogs
do stuff to houses people shouldn't
because they were trashy people and so
on they've got a lot of blame on their
side of this but that their side of the
equation I can't control my side of the
equation I can control so it never
happens again I'll put in my lease
conditions have to be met and you have
to and I'm gonna do you know once at
least once a quarter walkthrough and no
pets that's why I have no pets aya pets
at my house but not any of my properties
you don't like dogs no I love dogs I
hate dogs as a landlord
I really hate cats as a landlord you
can't get cat smell on another no way I
mean you have to burn the freaking house
down to get cat smell out of it so you
know no no kitties period no monkeys no
Petro ch's
nothing you know so whatever you know
and so in your you know and if I we
walked through really fine an animal you
leave her the animal leaves because your
lease said that you know so you learn
your lesson and you know you become a
little bit you know you start realized
you know owning property and being a
landlord is not it's not a charitable
donation and so it doesn't work through
charity that way you have to do your
ministry work otherwise now if you want
to have a house that's ministry and you
just let people live there that's
wonderful that's a whole different
scenario though but when your landlord
in you have to have set of guidelines
you go last time I did this it hurt I'm
not doing this again last time I let
somebody stay in there three months not
paying no no thinking they were gonna be
okay they're not gonna be okay you know
you're ten seconds late we're all over
you period and you know we're gonna
inspect the property and we're not mean
we're the best landlord you'll ever have
oh yeah there's just not tear my
freaking house down and pay your rent
why is that hard for some people well it
is because some people's parents didn't
raise them well and so you just got to
put your plot blocks in place regardless
of which of these directions you go
because you can control a lot of these
variables and not allow this to happen
to you again or you need to sell the
piece of real estate and if you're not
going to be an active hands on up in the
grill landlord that's what you're going
to face thanks for the call